[Music]
the town of bays Ville has a population
of 2,000 people
Jimmy is worried after reading a news
article about a disease called condition
itis condition itis is a serious but
rare disease afflicting 1% of the
population let's represent healthy
people as blue and disease people as
orange Jimmy decides to go to the doctor
to get tested
unfortunately Jimmy tests positive for
the disease in other words the test says
that he has condition itis we will
represent positive test results with
yellow Hat's
the test be wrong well the test is 95%
accurate what does this mean for Jimmy
note that there are two ways this test
could be wrong a person could test
positive for the disease when they don't
have it or the cat s negative when they
do have the disease there are also two
ways that the test could be right a
person who has the disease could test
positive or a person who does not have
the disease could test negative suppose
that 95% accurate means if a person has
condition itis then 95 percent of the
time they will test positive which would
be the correct diagnosis if the person
does not have condition itis then 95
percent of the time they will test
negative which again would be the
correct diagnosis in other words there
is a 5% chance of misdiagnosis in each
case given this information how sure are
you that Jimmy has the disease a he
almost certainly has the disease B he
probably has the disease C it's about
50/50 whether he has the disease or D he
probably does not have the disease
let's imagine that we conduct the test
for every single person in Bayes Ville
and assign each person who test positive
for condition itis a yellow habit
recall that healthy people are
represented as blue disease people are
represented as orange and a yellow hat
represents a positive test result since
the test is not 100% accurate some of
the people who get hats probably don't
actually have condition itis the
combination of the test results and the
true disease status classifies our
population into four groups true
negatives or healthy individuals who are
correctly tested as negative true
positives or diseased individuals who
are correctly tested as positive false
negatives or diseased individuals who
are incorrectly tested as negative and
false positives or healthy individuals
who are incorrectly tested as positive
if we just look at the negative results
our test seems pretty good after all it
only missed one diseased person however
looking at the positive test results we
find that a large majority of the
positive test results are actually false
alarms this is good news for Jimmy his
positive test result does increase his
chance of being diseased but with so
many false positives it turns out that
there's only a 16% chance he's actually
sick there's an 84% chance he does not
have condition itis so Jimmy stops
panicking but decides to get a second
opinion just in case
did you make the right prediction in
general we need to take into account the
rarity of a disease not just the
accuracy of a test and we need to
distinguish between the probability of
having a disease given that you test
positive and the probability that you
test positive given that you have the
disease
[Music]
you
you